- It's complicated.
That's a description that
applies to a lot of activity
in and around Washington these days,
but especially applies to
one of the most important
relationships President
Joe Biden is working on.
His long acquaintance
with Israeli prime minister,
Benjamin Netanyahu.
These two leaders have been
joined anew in recent days
of course, by the rising
tensions between Israelis
and Palestinians and specifically
the outbreak of violence
between Israel and Hamas
forces in the Gaza Strip.
President Biden and
Prime Minister Netanyahu,
have talked numerous times
during the course of this crisis.
And publicly Mr. Biden has
largely defended Israel's right
to respond with military
force to Hamas rocket attacks
saying, "It was entitled
to act in self defense."
- The United States fully
supports Israel's right
to defend itself against
indiscriminate rocket attacks
from Hamas and other Gaza
based terrorist groups
that have taken the lives of
innocent civilians in Israel.
- Privately he reportedly
has been much tougher
with Mr. Netanyahu, saying,
"He expected him to deescalate
the situation and deal with
Palestinian grievances."
His nudging may have led to the ceasefire
that's finally taken hold but these two
are far from done with each other.
Now the Biden administration
inevitably will be deeply
involved in trying to
broker a broader agreement
to simultaneously deal with
Israel's security concerns,
as well as Palestinian simmering anger
at the way they're treated
by Israel, not just in Gaza,
but also in the West Bank and Jerusalem,
and increasingly inside Israel itself.
The long history of this
relationship shows President Biden
is prepared to push Prime
Minister Netanyahu to go further
than he wants to accommodate
Palestinian demands.
But also that he's more
likely to do his hard pressing
privately rather than publicly.
- I don't talk about what
I tell people in private.
I don't talk about what
we negotiate in private.
- [Narrator] These two
men have known each other
since the early 1980s
when Mr. Netanyahu was
the second in charge
at the Israeli embassy in Washington,
and then later Israel's
ambassador to the United nations.
Mr. Biden meanwhile was a US Senator
developing a particular
interest in foreign affairs.
They came into closer contact in the 1990s
when Mr. Netanyahu became prime minister
and Senator Biden was
on his way to becoming
the top Democrat and eventually chairman
of the Senate Foreign Relations Committee.
They were in these positions
of power in the early 2000s
when the George W. Bush
administration was both marshaling
an international response to
the 9/11 terrorist attacks
and also trying to get peace talks going
between Israel and the Palestinians.
Their relationship became more important
during the Obama administration
when Mr. Biden was vice-president
and Mr. Netanyahu again
became prime minister.
Their relationship also became
more tense in those days.
The Obama administration
put a high priority
on finding a new Israeli
Palestinian peace accord.
Vice-president Biden was
visiting Israel in March, 2010,
trying to assure Israel of
American support for its security
in any such peace deal
when the Netanyahu administration
announced the construction
of hundreds of new housing units
for Jews in East Jerusalem,
the part of the city where
Palestinians envisioned
putting the capital of a
Palestinian state someday.
Israeli housing there is one
of the most sensitive issues
for Palestinians and one that
US officials have long thought
undermines the chances for diplomacy.
Mr. Biden was blindsided
and he wasn't happy.
There were tensions again
on another front in 2015,
when Prime Minister
Netanyahu visited Washington,
and at the invitation
of Republican leaders
delivered a speech to a
joint session of Congress
devoted to attacking the Iran Nuclear Deal
the Obama administration
was then negotiating.
- The greatest danger facing our world
is the marriage of militant
Islam with nuclear weapons.
To defeat ISIS and let
Iran get nuclear weapons
would be to win the
battle, but lose the war.
We can't let that happen.
(crowd clapping)
- [Narrator] Obama administration
officials were furious
and vice-president Biden who
normally would have attended
such a speech was notably absent.
Through these tensions,
President Biden and
Prime Minister Netanyahu
appear to have maintained
a good relationship,
one in which they are generally
supportive of each other
publicly, but have blunt
and sometimes acrimonious
conversations in private.
Mr. Biden in particular
seems to have decided
to avoid the public sparring
that hurt president Obama's
relationship with Israel.
These two men are now being tested anew,
as it is it may be that their
relationship is shored up
by one characteristic that they share.
Both Joe Biden and Benjamin Netanyahu
are very good at the art
of political survival.
(soft dramatic music)